my god what episode are we on
okay that's what i was looking for thank
you kai we're live we're live
okay we are live with episode number 18.
by the way everybody adam came in
ready he's got his black shirt on you
may want to unbutton one more to show
him
your chest like show it put the chain
out but the channel ricky would be
full-on ricky would have a tank top on
us what he would be doing
but uh what a night yesterday huh the
debate
what a night yesterday obviously we'll
talk about it here in a minute for
uh the vp debate folks uh thanks for
joining us press that like button
and uh before we get into let me lower
the audio here before we get into it
i want to ask you guys for one thing
last night's debate what was
the score okay pence kamala put your
score down i want to hear from everybody
put your football
score down we'll give ours here in a
minute as well but uh we got a lot to
cover today uh
obviously uh uh i still hear somebody
else's audio
because mine is on mute just so you guys
know as yours
yeah okay good so we're good to go now
so we've got a lot of things to cover
here
uh trump administration announced the
overhaul of the h1b1 visa program why
he's doing it
um you have to pay the folks from on the
h1b one more than the american people
which is
pretty interesting what things they're
talking about but we'll get to that here
in a minute
stock rises as trump appears to soften
stance on stimulus first he said no i'm
not going to do it until i get elected
then he changed his mind and said i'm
going to be doing it so we'll see what's
going to happen there
uh tech giants have scored a regulation
because of not monopolies have been
defined by law democrats are now
trying to rewrite those laws the end of
oil jobs uh trump's new ad
video which you got to see it'll remind
you of the apple
think different video we haven't touched
up on this topic yet we're going to try
to get it in today europe european
silicon valley maybe we get into that
king of all median income howard stern
you will not believe the contract he
just got
it's ridiculous the contract he just got
and then
the pope the pope says uh capitalism
doesn't work we need to change it you
know so maybe we need to listen to what
he has to say vp debate
ballot harvesting maybe we'll get into
that and uh
mba is thinking about getting away from
the blm campaign that they had this year
and a weird sign that showed up on the
side of the 405 freeway which was pretty
interesting we'll get into that too as
well but let's first talk about
the most important topic for the first
ten minutes
of today's podcast howard stern oh
that's number one so so the debate
was a few months ago joe rogan got a 100
million dollar contract from spotify
okay
the number is over four-year period some
are saying it's more than that somewhere
since it's not 100 million over four
years some close friends are saying we
know the number
it's much more than 100 million i would
say his contract needed to be around a
quarter of a billion dollars
that's what i would say over four years
50 a year i think joe's a 50-year guy
no question about it but here's what
just happened
howard stern okay who's
on siriusxm radio okay
if you've ever listened to a show and
said to yourself gee i know howard
stern's making 90 million a year but man
i think he's underpaid
some other people agree his bosses think
he's underpaid
bloomberg.com just reported that serious
xm holdings is working on a contract
that would give stern you ready for this
120 million
dollar salary per year let me say this
one more time
120 million your salary not 120 million
dollar contract
not 120 million over five years not 120
million over three years
120 million dollars per year
at the age of 71 the moment they
announced this
serious stock dollars and ninety five
cents seven
percent it increased the moment the
announcement was made
that he's getting that kind of a raise
so is it worth it or not a hundred and
twenty million dollar a year
tom easy answer very very easy answer
one word answer
no he is not worth not worth not worth
it was he
yeah probably more in the past wow 2005
2006 when he came over to siriusxm and
built it and and made it into what it is
yes and here's why i say no okay he was
making 90.
now i'm a fan of howard i like howard
he's tailing off okay he's not into it
as much as he was
the show is suffering in my opinion and
here's the other thing that why it's not
worth it he's become
political and that means you are going
to alienate half your audience
and i guarantee you there will be people
canceling their subscription to siriusxm
because of his support his blinding
support for biden
his hatred now for trump it's gotten
over the top
and i thought him and trump with friends
obviously right and they they
they used to be but he's using that as
an excuse now um that he doesn't support
him and and
look this is a subscription-based model
yeah okay
people can make the decision with with
their credit card
and now look these guys aren't idiots at
siriusxm they know what they're doing
the stock went up because i think they
were so afraid
that he wasn't he he get he hangs them
you know he's got them by the short
hairs all the time
because he's he's messing with him
whether he's gonna resign another
five-year deal but i do not believe
it's going to be worth it for five more
years at a buck 20 a year
600 million dollar contract because of
because of his political stances now
dude the guy's currently making 90
million
a year are you freaking kidding me yeah
so he's do he's do is do a raise
inflation 120 million are you kidding me
even if he gets a meets in the middle
between 90 and 120 and settles on
105 million howard doesn't settle okay
he won't settle on anything on that deal
howard stern comes again his latest book
that just came out i think a year ago
yeah the thing with howard stern he's
the og in this he is the
you wrote the king of all median income
was that like a pun yeah okay it was
good
um king of all media man he started this
thing there'd be no joe rogan there'd
be no pbd podcast there'd be no podcast
if it were not for howard stern he
jumped ship from radio what
12 15 years ago to siriusxm
homie makes 90 million dollars a year
here's the here's the thing about howard
stern
whatever guest he wants he gets you want
trump
on he gets trump you want hillary
clinton on you get hillary clinton you
want musical acts he gets musical acts
you want the biggest stars in the world
they come on howard stern first and
foremost
now i think it's fair to say joe rogan's
coming for his crowd
right i mean as far as viewership as far
as credibility as far as getting guests
but how it turns to og so is he worth 90
million
obviously they're paying them that is he
worth 120 million
potentially the guy's gonna get a
hundred million no doubt
and he's 65 he'll be 71 at the end of
this contract right
the guy's still got some gas left in his
tank i don't think he's done whatsoever
you got trump who's 72 73 how are you
7474. trump 74. biden's 104
yeah uh that's good he doesn't look 140.
he looks like 85 you know
minimum minimum 85. how about that shot
from behind of biden where he's bald
they hide that very very well but he is
flat out bald on the back side of his
head
it looks pretty rough what are you
saying about both people i'm just saying
that i did just because you got a good
hand
i thought biden was more vibrant but
when you look at him from behind man he
is bald don't look at him from behind
look at him straight in the eye
dead in the eye so so you're saying he's
worth it you're saying i'm saying he's
the king
here's what i'm saying i'm saying it's
not worth it to siriusxm
i say they're gonna have a ton of
cancellations so let me ask you this if
they don't go after him who do they go
get at that level
nobody there is no other name at that
level you know no other names
you ever watch remember when they
changed the contracts a couple years ago
mike connolly got a 160 million dollar
contract for four years you're like mike
conley yeah who's
who's getting 164 what are you paying
this gun
and the lakers signed a massive deal
with uh lua deng
do you remember what you're doing but
they're still paying the price yeah
they're still paying the price i'm like
what are you guys doing i know
what is this all about with this
contract but sometimes when the talent
pool
isn't big you gotta pick up or else
somebody else is going to pick up
because because here's the numbers if
you look at sirius xm
stock hi can you pull up siriusxm stock
just look at siriusxm stock in the last
12 years
okay if you look at siriusxm stock
uh right there go max go max yeah let's
just say it goes
look at that at 100 go a little bit more
to the left it's 8 58 60 gold one more
56 bucks wow and now it's gone down
down down go keep going to the right all
the way to the right all the way to the
right
look at that you know they're trying to
barely make it together like
yesterday z takes my car yeah and she
says
pat i noticed your radio stations and
your car weren't fixed so i fixed them
and i put some radio stations for you to
listen to kai
starts laughing over there and he's
laughing and she's not paying attention
to kai said
see i don't know if you know or not i
don't i don't listen to anything on the
car in the car
she says but you got serious excellent i
said i honestly didn't even know i had
siri sexism
but i gotta tell you five ten years ago
when cars would say it comes with sirius
xm you know you're like
oh my gosh serious except
today it's a whole different story
people are all tuned into a podcast
people are listening to something else
this is the other part i will say about
this thing here uh i will say
the interview that he recently did with
hillary clinton you know what everybody
said he got her to talk about stuff i
think even you said
it was phenomenal yeah he got her to
talk about stuff that maybe no one's
ever talked about before
maybe howard's about to go on the second
run and he's pitched them behind closed
doors saying there's the one thing i've
never touched
it's politics i think i can get things
out of people that others can't i don't
know
i know howard's a sales guy if you you
know if you know the guy's story the
guy's a very good sales guy
okay i'm sorry go ahead and there's
there's no way
someone's giving a guy 120 million
dollars without
thinking in the back end that this guy's
going to deliver so they're banking on
them too there's not a lot of talent
right now
that's at that level three rogan just
signed with spotify the biggest fear
uh uh the best thing that happened to uh
howard stern
believe it or not is the fact that
spotify said they're getting broken and
outside of that
siriusxm is sitting behind closed doors
you know what they're worried about
who just announced four weeks ago
they're going in the podcast game
who just announced amazon are you
kidding me a two trillion dollar company
said we're going into podcast so
seriously
and they're saying dude they'll pay this
guy 120 million that's nothing for them
so there's a lot of things behind
closers that you don't know about where
howard may be coming up saying look i
got a
i got amazon came knocking man and i'm
taking the call i'm going to have a
meeting with them
amazon so you know what else i think too
if you listen to howard like i said i'm
a fan of howard i just think he's lost a
step on his game i really do
what do you mean by lost he's not as
good as he used to be his interviewing
abilities are phenomenal how often does
he do big interviews it's not that who's
coming in the studio
with covet no one's coming in there
anymore howard's scared as hell anyway
he's doing the show from
from the hamptons a couple things
howard's a loyal guy
he protects his guys and those guys
don't have careers without him right
the happiest people are jd baba bowie
robin's okay on her own but i think he
does that to keep those guys
relevant at least a little fraction of
it he really you know they helped build
him
by the way trivia question who replaced
howard stern when he left
uh terrestrial radio in 2005 who
replaced him david lee roth
can you freaking believe that it lasted
about two months he came on so cocky
uh so arrogant so out of touch i think
it lasted two or three i mean he he did
not appreciate howard he didn't respect
him
and he was blasted out of there uh
almost immediately and that rest of the
people
doesn't work you can't come in and doing
things like that rest in peace eddie van
halen
speaking of david yeah i mean i was in a
meeting with the investors when uh uh
uh ian announced that eddie van halen
died at 65 years old and
you know mario's a big fan and i think
everybody's listened to his music
obviously you've got somebody like that
with that kind of talent coming up
uh one time he told us a story about one
time um
is it black sabbath who who was uh who
was part of black sabbath
uh uh let's see let's get mario in here
who's
alice cooper no it's not cooper who's
the who's part of black sabbath leader
so one time they're doing a concert and
they said uh they said van halen is
opening up
and he comes up to open up he crushed it
better than
the main show and from that point on
he left who's the guy yeah ozzy osbourne
left saying
the hell with you guys he left and
started something else he said because
if these guys got their stuff together
like this
right anyways it's a rest in peace
when's the last time you watched howard
stern
i don't watch her listen i don't watch i
just know his story so you don't watch
him
and you you know from time to time well
you know what he's got three channels so
you can get the recap so sometimes i'll
do that every once in a while but
you know let me tell you i don't watch
all that i'll listen i don't watch all
that often but i'll tell you what is
sick that i have watched episode after
episode just kind of went on a binge
he has top musical acts show up in the
studio earlier
before kovid and jam out counting crows
katy perry
just the list goes on and on those are
some of the episodes i watch but
musical acts show up sing their songs a
cappella rock out have a band there
it's pretty freaking dope listen i'm
telling you
i'm for paying them you don't pay the
market is going to pay whether you like
it more now market's going to pay this
guy
the whole mike connolly story yeah you
don't want to pay me
no problem there's only 300 nba players
out there 280 of them are signed 20 of
them are looking for a contract you're
dealing with 20
you're going to pull people from college
for puerto rico i'm in the top 20
players that are available to buy you
want to buy me come pay me
the current contracts or 160. so he got
paid by the way yeah you know what uh
howard stern just did
let me tell you what howard stern just
did howard stern
just made joe rogan a billionaire
i'm gonna say this one more time joe
rogan is officially a billionaire
and he's a billionaire five years he's
got to wait it's it's gone his way
yeah in five years he's going to get a
200 million dollar year contract
in five years in five years level up the
playing field no this is all it might do
when steve ballmer bought the clippers
yeah michael jordan became a billionaire
sure when steve ballmer bought the clip
increase the value
an organization that was worth nothing
san diego clippers is when sterling
donald sterling bought him and he was a
commercial real estate guy and he could
care
less about the nba could care less about
the nba baltimore paid 2.2
every nba owner said thank you bomber
you officially made us richer
right howard stern officially made a lot
of people rich
that's a good point so hey more power to
all the podcasts let me give you a mike
calling analogy that will not
uh mike connolly get his name mike
conley yeah yeah memphis grizzlies
he just got traded to utah but here's
what's gonna happen with talent like
this talent like joe rogan
yeah mike conley signs a five-year 150
million dollar contract whatever it was
with the
memphis grizzlies first two three years
cool he's doing great he's an all-star
and then what happens to a lot of these
contracts they fall off
they get traded he ends up in utah he
does he's not doesn't do as well
all of a sudden you're paying 30
something million for a guy who's
a questionable starter respect to my
colony though that's not going to happen
with talent like this no
like he's going to be he's not going to
lose his mind or lose his no
gas in the tank or lose his wheels three
four years ago for a while he's going to
go for a look
in reality much love to howard stern for
getting his money i respect him if you
can get your money go get it you got it
good for you
that's the game of capitalism i i i
respect anybody that can negotiate
behind closed doors and get paid what
they get paid in this kind of dollars
you bring value where the market's
willing to pay this kind of money more
power to you more people do you think he
gets 120 million bottom line i don't
know if he does or not all i'm saying is
the bench isn't deep the market a free
agent isn't big at this level
no he's getting 120 especially if he's
going to get it of course he's going to
get it just saying he's not worth it
no i was saying i i i don't think it's
ultimately going to be worth it to
siriusxm
but he's going to get the buck 20
because it's already been talked about
he's not settling for a penalty
check this out look you know how hard it
is to keep people's attention people
think it's an easy game
so howard stern's been on radio for how
long i mean 40 years 40 years okay
he's replaced by who david lee rod how
long did trump run apprentice
15 years who was he replaced by
a very big person arnold schwarzenegger
he couldn't do apprentice
yeah it's not the easiest job to keep
people's attention
even even with a name like
arnold right movie star how long did
arnold's lives
barely a year no and he was horrible and
part of the problem is
those guys have such confidence and
their egos are so big they could they
think they can step right in
take it another direction make it even
better and it doesn't because that you
know that show was trump and and no one
can replace house that's not how it
works you got to do more than that when
you're talking about this by the way
tech giants okay
let's talk about european silicon valley
so the founder of spotify daniel
daniel eck said he would invest a
billion euros 1.2 billion dollars of his
personal fortune in deep tech moonshot
projects spread across over
10 years he indicated that he was
referring to machine learning
biotechnology material sciences and
energy as a sector he'd like to invest
in
i want to do my part we all know the one
the greatest challenges is
access to capital he said adding he
wanted to achieve
a new european dream meaning similar to
the american dream he wants to create a
silicon valley
and start a european dream i get really
frustrated when i see european
entrepreneurs giving up on their dreams
amazing vision selling early on to
non-european companies or when some of
the most promising tech
talent in europe leaves because they
don't feel
valued here we need more super companies
that raise the bar
and can act as an inspiration thoughts
will this work a european silicon valley
not to the level that we have not even
close
but i i applaud him i think that's
admirable because i think these
entrepreneurs these tech
genius entrepreneurs in europe don't
have a level playing field for what we
have here because we have a free country
where it's easier to do it
i think there's limitations because of
government so when i see him stepping up
like this
as long as it's sincere i'm all for it i
think it's a great idea what city is it
going to be in is there going to be a
central location
because that's the biggest problem that
they're going to face type in european
silicon valley
eck ek type european silicon valley
go ahead adam yeah i think he's based
out of stockholm i want to say
i don't think stockholm sweden is going
to be the next silicon valley i don't
think it's going to be double in ireland
i don't think it's going to be
london per se for tech i don't think
it's going to be paris i don't know if
they work hard enough
brussels that's where the um the head of
the eu is right in brussels
um people are saying lisbon portugal is
a good place to
start up tech um germany munich berlin
but i'm naming all these cities because
that's how fragmented it potentially
could be
in america we know if you want to get
involved in the tech game
you go to san francisco silicon valley
straight up done
you want to get involved in the
financial game you go to new york done
you want to get involved in hollywood
you're moving to l.a
you want to have a little of best of all
worlds you go down to miami yeah
you know where to go it's very
fragmented here so i respect this guy
i'm not sure what european where's
daniel elect from kai do you have a
quick
quick country for me is he swedish
whatever he is i respect him for trying
to keep talent here in
europe but i don't think anything is
going to be replaced in still
silicon valley anytime soon look at all
the companies that have come out of
silicon valley
right google amazon well did amazon come
out of silicon valley well
paypal um the list goes on facebook
obviously apple all the list goes on and
on and what's come out of europe what
name account name a company is why
that's the question is why why hasn't it
take a look at your phone and bring that
tweet up about greg app and what he just
said yesterday why
why has no company come out of europe
because there's no central location for
them all to go
oh that's why so you're saying the
reason why it hasn't come out of europe
is because of central location and where
to go i'm saying there is no central
location okay i'm not saying that's the
reason why so so let me explain to you
so the other day
i sat down with the ceo of aig of uk
london he's now the ceo of ig so he and
i had a meeting together
uh a few months back okay and
sharp sharp guy the division that he's
running he's the ceo for
and we were thinking about expanding to
uk and london when i went to london on
one night
i sent a instagram and i said i'm gonna
do a meet up by this one bridge
a hundred people showed up at 9 30 and
it's raining we have the video we
couldn't play mike wait a minute
and you know how many the guys showed up
they're like we're in insurance what are
you opening up we want to work for
you know the company in php in the uk
i'm like in uk now
let me look into it let me look into it
so we meet up we start talking
i said so what does it take for me to uh
uh go through licensing in uk says oh
you have to be a cfp you have to be at
this you have to be a full-timer you
cannot be a part-timer you have to
he went through step by step by step if
you can pull up the tweet
step by step by step process i just text
it to you
yeah step-by-step process on all this
stuff here's what greg yappa tweeted
yesterday
i've been talking with nasdaq stock
exchange about moving some of their
operations to texas
they want to flee high taxes let them
know
that we just passed i let them know that
we just passed a constitutional
amendment
banning an income tax in texas
that's how you get entrepreneurs to be
free
so there's a reason why there's not a
silicon valley in all these companies
being built in europe
you can put all the billions of dollars
danny elect don't waste your money
they're going to tax the hell out of it
you're going to get so tired of it
you're going to come back and say dude i
thought this was going to be a different
story
these regulations are not just going to
let it happen it has nothing to do
with dreamers it had nothing to do with
the people that have a vision
he's got a very good point when he says
here
i get really frustrated when i see
european entrepreneurs giving up on
their amazing vision selling early on to
non-european companies
why do people sell early on to
non-european companies because they are
regulated and they want to sell it to
somebody else
and they're just kind of like i don't
want to mess with it anymore or when
some of the most promising tech talent
in europe
leaves because they don't feel valued
here it's not about they don't feel
value to your body
they got they got restraining they got
they got all these different
regulations yeah you know can you put
that tweet up again
okay so here's what i think i look at
this it's brilliant number one
i look at it as a trial balloon he goes
east right talking to nasdaq
about possibly moving to texas do you
think potentially
a tech company could leave silicon
valley
one of the big ones because those guys
want to make money too they will tesla's
talking about that aren't they
could you freaking under believe that i
mean well he he's
you know he's a he's an outlier you know
elon musk but i've talked about one of
the big ones in silicon valley i
actually do and i think it's eventually
going to happen look guys i'm telling
you you
there's one thing you can't do to uh i
was having a conversation with who were
we talking about yesterday when i said
you can't have so so i look at the
the the folks i work with in our company
right and i look at certain
personalities
whom others can coexist in okay they can
coexist in
we have a guy uh who's a very good
friend i've i've mentored this kind his
wife for quite some time now
jose marlin gaitan okay they
you've been around them before i don't
know if you've had a chance to meet him
you've been around that before
how chill too chill how chill of a guy
hey man
okay can you coexist around him yeah
very good does he make you feel like
you're comfortable being around him
does he make you feel like he's the man
you better respect him or else you can't
be around him not at all
it's not his personality he's chill
right okay so
when you're in certain markets like you
are
in uh what do you call it in a silicon
valley
and you're on all this other talent
sometimes you gotta go
to a different place yourself like in
austin
and not pay the taxes and people think
people are never gonna leave
they're gonna be here forever you cannot
have creative talent stay in a place
confined
to handcuffs and shackles and over
regulation because
eventually talent who's very innovative
they have to be what
it's the f word it's the f word that
kamala used last night
free but it's a different kind of a free
it's free to say what
listen like when we deal with these guys
that are doing uh our sound and they're
working on getting better
i don't hover over them let's just guys
just get better
let's figure this thing out what are we
doing just get better it's all we got to
do we got to get better right no no no
no you can't do that too much you got to
let people be free let us figure out
what as long as you deliver because free
thinkers who are doers
they just want to be left alone they're
not going to do it in europe so i don't
see this thing going too much
uh uh in europe because of regulation
let me ask you a question
because you're you're you live in
california you're from california you
brought up the
over regulation point california is
pretty high taxes and pretty
high regulation right that's where
silicon valley is based so what's the
what's the metaphor there what's the
what's the great question can you pull
up a 405 freeway check this out here's
what's going on in california secretly
that a lot of people don't know about by
the way this just happened
this week they took down the hollywood
sign and actually replaced it this is
the ktla
that's 405. i've gone down this road god
knows how many
tens of thousands of miles and they put
the trump sign over there
okay and by the way those mountains are
always on fire just so you know no
literally no of course
how it's black yeah those mountains are
always on fire i'll let you know if that
sign is still up this weekend
yeah i have a funny feeling it won't be
or it'll be defaced or something whether
it will be or not because it's not hard
to go to it and do whatever you want to
do to break it
you know you obviously if you burn it
you're going straight to prison because
you're an arsonist but
there's a lot of things you can you can
do with that moral of the story is this
there are going to be certain people in
the state of california
that are either behind closed door
conservative fiscally conservative
entrepreneurs innovators who are getting
sick of the regulation who are either
going to leave
or there's going to be those that are
just going to come out publicly
and if california doesn't eventually
change you're not going to keep them
forever that's not how life works
okay you can be in a lot of people
uh that you see are married for 25 years
and then they get a divorce you ever see
people that get married for 25 years and
get a divorce
like you got a divorce after 25 years
bazel's got a divorce after 25 years
what happens all the time right
well why didn't they marry at five years
why not at 10 years
kids a lot of times it's kids a lot of
times i don't want to do it because
we've got kids you know let's just wait
you know let's make it work we're going
to love you they're comfortable
or they're comfortable but eventually
dude if you abuse a woman for too long
dude eventually she's just
i can't do it anymore i'm out right vice
versa i'm out vice versa
vice versa yes so if you do this to
california eventually people going like
dude listen
i love you california like listen you
have no idea how much i love the state
of california
you have no when i go to california and
i see it i can't even help myself how
much i love the state
but you're eventually going to push
people out so i like abbott's move and i
don't think this is going to work in
europe not because daniel eck is not
doing a noble thing trying to help
people out
he needs to spend that money on
regulation he needs to come and say hey
europe you want to create a silicon
valley yes before i put my 1.2 billion
guess what i'd be doing what's that
here's the five things you guys got to
do in whatever country
offers these five things low regulation
no taxes all of this stuff that he goes
through i'm gonna put that 1.2 billion
into your country
and we're going to make that the hub of
silicon valley that's the approach i
would take
you never go and say hey guys here's 1.2
billion no hold it back
whoever does these five things we're
coming to your state so but it's not my
money it's just money can i tell the
audience how much you love california
can i tell them how much
i love l.a i went with pat we actually
met for lunch one day
i went with pat i think this was like
two three weeks ago he wanted me to
experience his entire city
so badly that he drove around the entire
city driving 165 miles per hour around
the entire
adam i want you to see everything
everything so he he showed me the entire
city it was a blur
yeah 65 miles per hour
can i make one observation silicon
valley that i could never figure out and
you tell me
if you feel the same way my daughter
grew up in san jose okay so i was in san
jose
twice a month for 15 years pepperdine
daughter yeah she went to college at
pepperdine but she grew up and went to
high school and everything in the bay
area
there is no energy in silicon valley
like you cannot
it is not just no energy it's dead i
could never figure out why whenever i
get off the plane and walk through the
airport
in san jose and i'm in the heart of
silicon valley it felt so dead i was so
happy
when i didn't have to go there anymore
you know i just dreaded it almost just
because
of you know of what it felt like but for
a place so vibrant and so many creative
people and so much money
it just feels dead tom maybe you don't
know the right places
because maybe you don't know the right
spots to go to because what i know about
guys up there they're some of the
biggest party animals in the world some
of the guys behind closed doors
they put the most ridiculous underground
parts i know about your stories yeah
they're insane
yeah you want to get invited you don't
get incredible you get if you're single
you want to go through i couldn't
go to him because i was always hanging
out with my daughter but i got it well
there you go
there you go you gotta you went to a
different kind of a party a family party
okay
uh uh is it time for us to go into the
vp debate
and just kind of talk about the vp
debate here okay so
if you're watching this i saw a bunch of
the scores you guys posted by the way we
got fifty dollars from
let me see ricky bobby's on with us
today guys
ricky bobby is on the podcast tell you
if you ain't first or last
it first your last you want to gain too
want to go fast
you want to go to 500 000 subscribers
start talking about the independent
contractors that haul freight
we never stop well thank you ricky bobby
for that 50 dollars
uh uh that you put out the lunches on
ricky bobby yeah it is
so so let's get right into it gang okay
so what was the score i saw a bunch of
scores up there somebody said zero zero
someone said 29 27 what was the vp
debate score
did it keep you going did you like it
more than the presidential debate so
prior to going on to all the issues kai
if you if you want to pull up all the
topics that they debated
pull that up um the topics that was uh
discussed on a vice presidential debate
uh let me see what you got here do you
have any notes here yourself kind of vp
debate or no is there anything he asks
here or no
nothing really here okay so last night's
debate what'd you think about it
do you want my score or you want to know
okay it's not fair to ask me this
question by the way because i am a
professional sports commentator okay so
if i give you a score and it's a
metaphor for a football game you know
i'm gonna be right
tell us so i already won this it was 25
to three 25 to three
you also before you say who wants you
obviously you obviously lean very far no
i don't
i i i evaluate what i see i evaluate and
i'm going to tell you
here's why it's 25 to 3. he scored four
touchdowns
four he missed three extra points okay
so he's not perfect he's not even really
that good
wow terrible but it's the little things
it's the fundamentals sometimes
um yeah 20 and she got a she she got a
late field goal i mean look i was
i was not i did not think it was a great
debate maybe the bar was set so low
from the first presidential debate but
at least that was compelling
it mattered now this one may matter
because of the age of the real
presidential candidates
which frightens me even more you know
after watching that but i didn't think
it was a great debate i didn't think the
moderator did a fantastic job
um i didn't think they brought a lot and
we can get into more details but i'm
going to give it a score of 25 three
pence
typical tom over here let's see what you
got let's see your score buddy
i got a hundred to zero kamala just
kidding
relax but what's yours i got i got 1313
as a tie in overtime there was no
clear winner i thought that was a debate
that first debate between trump and
biden was a
absolute [ __ ] show sorry if you're under
18 and listen to this show yeah
complete [ __ ] show trump acting like a
baby biden
couldn't hold it together that was
disgusting this was a real debate they
actually was substantive
they actually covered a lot of ground
they each had a couple different good
points i could
kind of go what i thought some good
points were i'm sure we'll get into it
but there was two things that they each
needed to do
pence i think i thought pence did a
better job defending trump's record than
trump did
straight up pence i mean if if i ever
have a vice president if i ever
want to run a company i want someone
like pence by my side no matter
how it's 1313 okay yes
because como did a great job because
what was kamal's job great
what was her point to do that all she
has to do is hold serve
she doesn't need she didn't parent her
to the left she said
she says i agree with fracking i'm good
that's called a lie
in the american it is is it she said
just a few months
ago that she i'm just saying that's what
she said there
so yeah but that's all that's a lie
buddy buddy
pence goes there and just lies like
crazy
trump doesn't lie like crazy you know
tell us how pants slide
i didn't say trump tell us how pens like
let's talk about the super spreader
event at the white house at the rose
garden okay let's just talk about that
yeah who's the head of the coronavira
task force
himself pence okay he said when they
said do you take any blame
for basically 25 people in the close
close close to the cabinet yeah
got covered kaylee mcilhenny hope hicks
yeah trump himself his wife i think
that's right ridiculous no i i think
half his cabinet has covet are you
freaking kidding me i think that's why
they made that the first topic because
they knew they were going to lose people
after the first topic and she gave
kamala a very easy soft softball here
you go
soft pitch here go hit this one here and
she opened it up with her line that she
had prepared because she knew the first
time
was the line what was the line yeah she
came out of saying this
is the worst handling of a crisis we've
ever seen in the history of america
you know i'm prefacing what you said but
something like that is what came out
so set the whole thing up but but tell
me about you
tell me that lack of responsibility but
lies with pens
number one he talked about the v-shaped
economy the recovery we know that it's
not a v-shape recovery maybe the
stock market is v-shaped maybe the rich
are getting richer but it's clearly a
k-shaped
economy okay okay we talked about how he
tried to
compare what's happening with covid but
the freaking v-shape
economy is a v-shape the stock market is
yes
the stock market the stock market isn't
the economy though it's a reflection of
the economy a reflection but it's not
unemployment went from eight point three
to seven point nine six hundred sixty
one thousand there's still twenty
million
people unemployed though but you already
employed half of them though
you're gonna do it in two months how are
you gonna employ all these people and
you you want him to do it in two months
are you kidding me it's been seven
months since covet started no it's
since of course since kovitz started
what i'm saying is from the peak
from the peak you want that recovery too
much it took it took
obama years to recover from what he had
would bush so you can't make the
recovery
buddy it's being recovered uh fairly
quickly for what they have the stock
market for sure and this and main street
jobs as well yeah i mean we i'm sure but
i want to know
i want to know specifically pence's lies
tell me where pence lied
where i thought he number one he he
ducked
many questions so did she so did she
so so did kamala like when they asked
the king of pence was very different
than kamala
kamala when it came to she know how to
court she
she bobbed and weaved like she was
muhammad ali straight up
pence would just not answer a question
they asked them repeatedly
have you discussed um a uh res
um a plan like a succession plan
what happens he didn't answer the
question didn't answer trump's health
the one with yes
did not answer the question did not
answer the question whatsoever
the fact that he tried to correlate h1n1
swine flu to what's happening now
is beyond laughable tell me why are you
kidding me how many people died of the
h1n1 buddy it's not the point of how
many people died
the the the swine flu wasn't as deadly
as this if it was those 60 million cases
that got it if the same rate applied as
covet
2 million people would have died if if
it's not about the if it's about the
fact that you let it spread
that's the part it's about you let it
spread and nobody shut down the economy
it was 60 million cases they got lucky
it wasn't deadly
how do you know how deadly a virus is
i'm not here to defend no but i'm not
here to i'm
no but what i'm trying to say is when it
comes down to let me tell you what i did
last night here's what i did last night
and i told this to generalization when i
went to bed and by the way for those of
you guys that are watching this for me
my opinion
it's one of the best debates i've ever
seen okay in a long time
okay and what when i say i'm talking uh
for me it's the best vp debate ever that
i've seen i mean i'm 41 years old i
haven't been around for a long time i
thought it was a great vp debate
here's how i watched it i tweeted ideas
that i said
i said pence doesn't seem
like a vp pence seems presidential
he doesn't look like a vp pence is the
kind of guy that if your son said i want
to grow up to be like pence you would
say okay
no prom sounds like a really good guy
sometimes on the other side like let me
tell you man trump inspired a lot of
people to be trumps
you know what i mean a lot a lot of
people are like living kids trump's
doing it i'm gonna do it as well
you know sometimes when somebody takes a
a new president that becomes a president
people take after that person's
personality
you know when obama was president you
were kind of like okay cool
you know my boy wants to grow up to be
like obama i'm good with that
you know because he was what he was a
suave dude yeah you know
i want to grow up to be like bill
clinton yeah i don't i don't know about
that buddy you know you may want to
think twice but maybe you one day be a
part of what's wrong with bill clinton
well you know some of the
ways personal life all this stuff you're
like i'm good with it i'm not about i'm
not listen i voted for the guy so i'm a
guy
i'm a fan of bill clinton if i put bill
and let's just say trump together
okay when i'm not as a leader remember i
am very logical in
policies i don't go emotions some of the
parties go emotional i don't go in
motion i go policies
i watch the baby i said i'm like dude
let me tell you
i would have no problem with my kids
sitting there my eight seven and
four-year-old sitting there listening to
the whole day i'm not comfortable then
watching the other debate
but if they watch your lesson like okay
issues that what is that that what is
vaccine
that what is this i love that we had a
conversation together right okay
here's the other part i watched him
and i said try hating him
try hating pence you can't do it a
rational person
no a rational person yeah try hating the
guy you can't do it
i say try hating trump
what's the answer very very easy to do
well it's the biggest topic
i mean yeah but what i'm saying is like
the way he comes in let me tell you i'm
the best and i'm perfect like right now
even this morning with mario bartoramo
he's like
my health has never been better in 20
years when you're 20 years older what do
you mean your health has never been
better
my health feels perfectly better i feel
perfect the keyword perfect you've got
clovid you're perfect
so what i'm trying to tell you but i
understand why some people may not like
his personality
i support policies i don't go
personality pence to me
was presidential yesterday kamala every
time she was losing she had that big
laugh the big laugh that she goes like
this
i think i got god let me laugh like it's
not a big deal and then
boom she didn't have an answer it would
happen twice both times there was one
time where
joe kept bringing up her record as a
prosecutor as what she did as a and that
was
she kept doing this she kept looking at
the moderator like hey change the
subject
it's like hey okay vice president mr
vice president
she's just looking to be saved and says
i will not be lectured
here to be undermined for my record you
asked me to score you asked me to score
28-7 pence killed it twenty-eight's not
even close
not even bro the fact that the way he
reacted
when they took shots was so imp yeah you
cannot learn that skill he's just kind
of standing there he's like
thank you susan you know uh first of all
when i saw you
uh my wife and i celebrated when i saw
you being selected and doing this this
was an incredible i wanted to
congratulate you in front of everybody
it was like oh thank you thank you and
you know but at the same time
uh look uh kamala harris you may have
the right to your opinions but you don't
have to write your
you know your truth he just went through
and the way he did it you're like
this is how this guy's gonna negotiate
behind closed doors are you kidding me
i'm good with this guy the way handles
it it seems so
presidential do you think he would ever
after trump yes
you think he would ever a run for
president and b do you think he has any
chance of being elected
i do you think so i do well yeah i do
but he has to pick his vp the other way
around by the way yeah
he's a wild man as his vp man but he
needs to pick his vp the way he's trump
you know he would never have a woman as
a vp never how do you know that because
he can't spend
time i literally cannot be alone in a
room with a woman i respect that you
know a couple things about that you know
when
no one knew who pence was when trump
picked him and maybe there was a method
to the madness because he almost is the
perfect counter balance
and you saw that last night just in
their personalities you mentioned pat
that how can you hate him you should see
some of the tweets from hollywood
joy behar alyssa milana yeah they hate
them
i mean i'm not surprised isn't it i mean
it's unbelievable but you got to realize
i understand why yeah here's my biggest
problem with kamala last night why i
think she got hammered
is a she lied okay joe biden did not
save the auto industry
i don't know how you can go up there and
just make that comment that joe biden
saved the audio
auto industry you know she's completely
lying about fracking they're going to
stop fracking a hundred percent
um i thought did pence miss an
opportunity by bringing up the fact that
uh she called joe biden a racist during
the presidency he missed a lot of
opportunities i mean that was the
biggest
opportunity that he missed and he's
never going to get a chance to do it
again i thought that was a
a huge gaffe by him and then my biggest
problem with her
when when the moderator asked her about
china and made the question
as specific as you could possibly be are
they an adversary an
enemy a competitor she didn't even
mention the word china
yeah i mean she didn't even answer it
and that answered the question to me
that she's in cahoots yeah well here's
here's what you got to think about kai
if you can pull up the
the topics that was brought up here's
here's how you got to think about that
so what is this this is
uh uh the vp i want the vp one
is this is this a vp debate and these
are the topics right okay let's go and
look at the topics
let's go look at the topics go down okay
go down uh
uh what was the one you had i just saw a
different one that okay is that the one
that it is okay
uh so they talk about trump fine covert
19. okay let's just say trump let's just
say trump is
a difficult person to defend and i
thought no one in the world could have
done a better job defending trump and
pence i don't think he could have said a
better thing defending his president
i think he crushed it i think he may be
one of the best number two guys i've
seen in a long time
if i ever have a number two i want a guy
like that no doubt oh by the way i also
thought kamala did a very good job
always bringing him back to joe i
thought she did a fantastic job saying
and under a joe biden administration and
i think joe biden is this and one of the
things about joe
she was doing she had a great job being
a flag it's not about have to
it's you have to know how to do that i
thought she did a phenomenal job on that
side defending her
candidate uh when they talked about
covert 19 they spend the most time
talking about
sure that makes sense that's what we're
going through then the economy
and then biden supreme court election
race foreign policy
you know what's keep going down keep
going down keep going down keep going
down keep going down
look how much time they spend talking
about china 45 seconds 45
seconds look how much time they spend
talking about abortion 43 seconds
43 seconds they should have spent more
time on it because roe versus weighed i
mean that's something that's going to be
uh uh what they're worried about with
the sec the stacking supreme yeah second
court but china you got 90 minutes the
number one enemy
okay the cause of this and susan
couldn't ask
more questions about china all i wanted
to know about was china it was like
china was like this
oh china okay okay okay let's go let's
go let's go terrible at follow-ups
she was horrible she just didn't want to
interrupt them and she wanted to make
sure that they weren't overgoing on
their time i mean that was her big
but by the way i tell you even though i
know she leans left
i thought she did a good job i i'm not
going to sit here and i thought
of course she interrupted uh pence a lot
more than kamala and when kamala's like
i need time to respond
she she gave it to her but she didn't
give it to him
there was those couple minutes where she
got too much like okay
i'll give you 30 seconds but he would
say i'll give you 15 seconds but he
would say i would give you 30. he would
keep going over the clock no but but he
has to
yeah but he never raised his voice when
he didn't get it so
he's so good she kept saying thank you
thank you
when i watch kamala harris and i look
i'm just stating the facts here
i can totally understand how she didn't
even make it to her home state
for a primary you know for the democrats
i mean she was not good she's not good
on stage she's not believable i find her
condescending
i mean that's it's scary to think
that um that she's that close and
and biden thought that highly of her
after everything that went down between
them personally
speaking of china i'll tell you a
memorable line i'm going to go down the
middle here i know you guys are going to
be shocked by me
just calling it like it is she he says
she said
trump lost the trade war to china that
was her claim
he says well biden never fought it
yeah that was big that was a big line
yeah okay respect
um she said uh
you know trump hates uh has called the
military suckers and losers she's
he's blasted john mccain she said listen
pence said listen my son is in the navy
my son-in-law is a marine
trump reveres the military okay so he's
gonna bring it back to his family
something tells me that even if trump
said those comments hypothetically
hypothetically pence would say sir
please
understand military like i think he
would make trump respect the military no
doubt
so and then the the thing that kamala
where she definitely lost points with me
was she refused to answer the question
on stacking the can you pull that up by
the way
or answer the question what do you think
about that though a non-answer like she
didn't even answer at all though there's
difference between avoiding versus like
not answering at all she was basically
saying
um well you want to talk about the
course
you want to talk about stacking the
court and then she like she's like
completely different directions she went
i was like where'd she go on that one
you know and she talked about
filling the supreme court with something
else um
they both talked about um brianna taylor
and justice i thought they both had good
responses
on that can you pause it because we
can't hear it kai just so you know
if you guys want to do audio on that do
we have audio this is a classic case of
if you can't win by the rules
you're going to change the rules now
you've refused to answer the question
joe biden has refused to answer the
question so i think the american people
would really like to know
if judge amy coney barrett is confirmed
with the supreme court of the united
states
are you and joe biden if somehow you win
this election going to
if so packed the supreme court to get
your way i'm so glad we went through a
little history lesson let's do that a
little more
in eight abraham lincoln i'd like you to
answer the question mr vice president
speaking
i'm speaking i'm speaking he is in 1864.
i think political heroes certainly of
the president i assume if you
also mr vice president is abraham
lincoln
abraham lincoln was up for re-election
and it was 27 days before the election
and a seat became open on the united
states supreme court
abraham lincoln's party was in charge
not only of the white house but the
senate can you show the clip of abraham
lincoln
honest abe saying that said show the
interview of abraham
lincoln on cbs america she thinks we're
so deserved to make the decision
that is so complicated we'll be the next
president watch this
and then that person can select who will
serve for a lifetime
on the highest court of our life i just
want to see him he's not you can tell
he's not even listening
to responses voting right now
and it should be their decision
about who will serve on this most
important body
for a lifetime watch this thank you
senator harrison
susan are voting right now they'd like
to know if you and joe biden are going
to
pack the supreme court if you don't get
your way in this nomination
let's talk about that you once again
gave a non-answer joe biden gave it
anonymous trying to answer you american
people deserve a straight answer and
and if you haven't figured it out yet
the straight answer is they are going to
pack the supreme court if they somehow
win this election
no but you got it you gotta show it
after that because there is a
there is there's a part right after that
when she says
i will show you okay go see if it's the
it's the 338 one there is a huge
fundraising deadline
go back how many minutes was that go to
the 338th one yeah that one right there
when you speak about the supreme court
keep going go to
two minutes and 20 seconds senator yeah
right there right there you haven't
figured it out yet the straight answer
is they are going to
pack the supreme court if they somehow
win this election watch this so
then susan changes the question but then
kamala gets pissed supreme court
if you cherish the separation of powers
you need to reject
the biden harris ticket come november
the 3rd re-elect president donald trump
and we'll stand by that separation
powers in a nine-seat supreme court yeah
let's talk about packing the court then
let's talk about this yeah i'm about to
i'm about to
you do know the trump pence
administration
has been because i sit on the senate
judiciary committee susan as you
mentioned
and i have witnessed the appointments
for lifetime appointments
she is very presentable district courts
parts of appeal
snobby people who are purely ideological
people who have been reviewed by
by legal professional organizations and
found to have been not competent
are substandard and do you know
that of the 50 people wait who
president trump appointed to the court
of appeals
i hope they leave the last seven seconds
of what he says
this is what they've been doing you want
to talk about packing a court let's have
that decision wait
kai oh they still didn't put it
i mean it's so the bias the media he's
cutting it off but you know what he says
right afterwards he says
just to get it on record she never
answered a question
yeah so which as someone who
you know picked a thai score here i will
say i deducted points for that you did
not answer the question human reaction
she never once shook her head if you
just watched her as he was saying that
if you had no plans of stacking the
court you'd be like
just instinctively you'd be shaking your
head she didn't do it
yeah pat a couple topics if we want to
address these they talked about
taxes yeah right and they talked about
um
four hundred thousand dollars raising
the taxes that they weren't a thousand
dollars
they would only raise it if you make
exactly only unless you make four
hundred thousand dollars
you believe that do you believe that do
i believe that do you believe i think
one way or another
one way or another whether it's
happening this year next year four years
taxes are going to have to go up in this
country no no but but on which
administration you think taxes are going
to go
up for sure the democrats okay so
but you're asking the things the
threshold the people making less than
400 thousand dollars are going to be
affected if they raise attention if they
they say they're not going to raise the
taxes on them you think they're going to
be affected what do you actually think
i'm actually asking a very serious
question
do i think that so she says and biden
says if you're making less than four
hundred thousand you're not going to be
affected do you think they're going to
be affected it depends if they change
the tax brackets is that what you're
asking
but they're saying they won't do you
believe they're like when obama
said i don't believe when obama says you
can keep your health if you like your
health engine you can keep it you're not
going to pay one new tax et cetera et
cetera
okay and then we have the 3.3 3.6 3.9
aca tax of course okay do you know who
lies you know who a liar is
you know who the biggest liar is both
sides every single one of them but
what i'm asking they all lie no but what
i'm telling you is trump said i'm gonna
lower taxes and he did
trump said he's gonna lower taxes and he
did corporate taxes right
of course when he did we have won the
highest corporate taxes in the world in
the u.s
u.s has won the highest corporate taxes
in the world he lowered it what from 35
to 20
23 some number like that right the day
he did it i give everybody here a
hundred dollar bonus
per month you've been with me you didn't
i didn't get anything man you weren't
here that was
three years ago should have let me out
here buddy retroactively by the way if
there is a
if there is again a lower taxes
everybody will get a bonus oh my
goodness
yeah but the point i'm saying the point
i'm trying do you actually think taxes
are not gonna go
go up for people making less than 400
do i think taxes are going to folks i
want you to get this on the record
he's pulling a kamala harris
let's talk about taxes let's talk about
taxes
let's have a conversation about taxes so
are you gonna
stack read my lips
no new taxes okay anyway let's talk
about the military let's talk about the
military
listen do i think taxes are going up yes
under biden
yes okay so biden gets elected the
people making less than four hundred
thousand taxes are still going to go
how low do you want to go though do you
think are you a hundred thousand do you
think the person making 36k is going to
be affected
no 100 percent they are you think you
think 100
100 percent so if you're if you're
making 36k you're in a 12 percent
yeah i'm going to tell you how you want
100 they are yeah yeah okay you raise
the corporate taxes what do i have to do
i have to fire five people
so right now i got more people working
because i can afford it
you fire them how much money have i
taken from vitamin
not much not much the answer is zero
it's been a loss every 50 of the guy
that gave us 50 bucks today we're gonna
take this that's going straight back
into the car
this is expensive to do all this stuff
right zero yeah what's the point here
it's not about like oh my gosh let me
take the money all this other stuff
i'm building a company just let me build
a company i'm going to hire people i
don't care what it is
these people get the work done and i do
my part i'm doing my part to build a
company we create an environment create
a good benefit plan we match 401k we
give good health insurance
we are in a fun environment to be and we
bring the right talent right okay
if he raises the corporate taxes from 23
to 35
i have to fire ten percent of my
employees but that's not what they said
they didn't talk about corporates but
what i'm saying but they don't but they
but
no no what she did say is day one
all the taxes that trump gave to his
rich friends we're going to revert to
that i did say that okay then so that's
exactly what they did but
that's two different types but it's not
too difficult tax rate and the uh
but but it's the federal income tax rate
if the corporate tax rate goes
up the 38 000 your person is affected
so i'm i'm good with the lower corporate
tax rate just so we're going to go
higher just so you know it's going to go
higher
i'm not good with the 35. i think as a
business owner you deserve whatever you
create jobs you're a job creator yeah
whatever you deserve a lower tax yeah
all i'm saying to you is
they're raising it and when they raise
it yes they can say we're not going to
raise taxes on the 38 000 person
okay fine let's say you are telling the
truth on that
but if you raise the taxes on corporate
they have to fire people
it's how things work right they have to
fire i'm with you on this yeah i'm with
you on this
that doesn't necessarily mean that the
federal income tax
rate is going to go higher or lower
you're just saying the ramifications of
a different
tax structure as a business owner okay
you'll have to look you'll have so
so i got this i got this uh a picture
here from a friend i won't say the name
because he probably doesn't want me to
mention that he sent me this
he sends me a picture saying vote to
raise taxes on the rich
property owners then on the bottom the
girl says
i'm confused why rent was raised
oh how come my rents go from 1200 a
month to 1400
a month because they raise taxes on the
people that own the corporate properties
i i'm confused how come i'm not getting
my raise that you guys were giving me
because score
i'm confused i used to get 40 hours a
week you just turned me part-time what
happened here it's because
administration that wants to raise taxes
got me to make you go part-time i'm
confused how come we're not given the
kind of health insurance we were given
before
because i'm confused how come we don't
have the 401k benefits we had before
because of corporate taxes are
increasing it's the highest in the world
u.s had the highest corporate tax rate
so what do you mean you're not going to
touch
that trump you're saying of course okay
so hypothetically
is obama it's the same tax rate yes
prior to trump increasing the corporate
tax rate yeah were companies doing okay
in america we're companies figuring out
where big
companies figuring out or the apple and
google which companies all companies no
wait a minute which companies were
figuring it out all companies big
companies were figuring it out i'm
i'm asking you weren't comfortable we
had figuring edge who had the biggest
edge big companies
yeah of course because they have the
dollars and they have lobbyists that
work to get certain laws and regulations
to make it harder
figuring it out too not at the same
level small businesses we're not coming
we're not
figuring it out the level as the other
guys were small businesses let them keep
the money and invest
back into the business listen do you
know the whole concept about rich people
buy rolls royces and ferraris and all
this other stuff all they do is waste
their money
do you know the cyclical cycle of how
money works whether you tax me five
percent
one percent zero percent twenty percent
the money is going back into the economy
do you want to unpack that message what
i just said right okay
let's just say you you have this because
the worry is the rich guy's gonna spend
the money to do what
buy yeah 500 000 watches and yachts and
boats and you know all this other stuff
right
i'm going to buy another vacation home
i'm going to buy this all this stuff
let's just say the guy has a lot filled
with lambos ferraris porsches all the
other stuff put all the crazy cars he's
got
he's the qualified rich guy that they
talk about okay
when you buy the lambo who creates the
lambo the workers
okay who who's getting paid for doing
the work
when you when you buy the lambo who does
the oil change when the tire gets broken
when 12 of my rolls-royce tires were
torn
within a span of 12 months each of those
tires were 8.50 who do you think made
money the tire company who think
made money the guy that put the tires on
who also think made money the guy that
had to come and told me from
i had to spend money it does the money
always goes back into the economy i'm
saying that's a trickle-down economy
even if the money stays in mutual funds
say i take the money and i say you know
what i'm going to do i'm going to put
all this money into the stocks
i'm going to put in the mutual funds
that money is being reinvested into a
job into
money's flowing constantly this concept
of money scaring the hell out of people
that we got a higher taxes
you know raise taxes on rich people what
are you talking about
somebody needs to take a basic math
class what do you mean if i raise the
taxes
we have the highest corporate tax rate
to say that we're going to revert back
to what it was day before
uh day before what do you call it trump
great go ahead and do that but you
cannot say
the people under 400 000 of your income
are not going to be affected like this
they're going to be affected you know
what the bottom line is
and this is the truth people's hatred of
trump
has precluded them the ability to think
straight i mean
the hatred for him supersedes anything
you know you can't make a rash decision
in this election because
the number one thing i mean if people
were to look at this objectively
and see you know like you i it's it's
your life's gonna change your taxes are
gonna go up the whole thing
but i think it's the the hatred of trump
is so
powerful that people can't make a rash
decision he brought it on to himself
though i mean yeah
you got to realize that part of it is
well you know
when you go out like that this is this
is how i see it
he came out the gates and the way he got
all the attention
is by saying what the people are
crossing the border and they're
raping their rapes some of them are
decent but they're
okay guess what he did his campaign was
let me
shock factor that was his campaign let's
just face it the way he went from being
no one on day one saw as a top 15 guy
they sam has a number 16 guy
he said i'm going to get the media on
the news and every day cnn bashed him
msnbc bashing msnbc they had him on
everything do you remember back in the
days when cnn and msnbc had him on every
day
every day they had them debate they they
hate
all of a sudden they're like dude we're
giving this guy too much so we have to
give him credit for his strategy
worked it worked but the other side is
your strategy also pissed a lot of
people off which you're going to have a
lot of enemies
you that's your game you played you
can't like the detroit pistons cannot be
ticked off that people hate them dude
that's you that's chuck daley but you
have to evolve a little bit too because
he's not the unknown anymore so he
he's he's bringing on some of these
bullets to him by the way
the pistons won multiple championships
like i'm not telling you that strategy
the philadelphia flyers of the 1972 i
don't know if you know the story the
1970s
dude these guys went and they played the
philadelphia flyers went and played
against
russians the olympian champions hockey
team they faced them
after this was a freaking uh what do you
call it when there was a match
not a it's a friendly match but they
call it something else not a submission
exhibition game do you know what
happened after the first period kicked
the [ __ ] out of them dude the russians
weren't coming out of the freaking
they weren't coming out of the locker
room the freaking prime minister
gorbachev had to call them and say what
the hell you guys are doing get the hell
out of there
you're not going to show russians for us
to be scared get because the
philadelphia flyers were whooping their
asses
yeah single-handedly kicking their ass
punching them hitting them
like literally literally they said we're
going to show you how we support them
dude that's how
you have seen that so you know what
happened you know what happened the next
year from 1972 to 1974 1974.
i was afraid of him the hockey rule book
went from this big to this big because
of the flyers it should
it should what i'm trying to say on
skates if you're chuck daily and you
want your pistons to play the way they
do
if you're the philadelphia flyers you
want your players to play they do if
you're trump
you're gonna get some i'm sorry you're
the most hated because that approaches
you're punking everybody
but it's the game he wants to play
that's totally fine what i'm trying to
do to the voter here's what i'm trying
to do to the voter okay
go to bush okay for example go to
clinton
when clinton did this stuff with monica
lewinsky like oh my gosh she should be
telling me
what he goes on dude i don't sit there
and watch the president and say
i gonna live my life based on your
values i'm gonna live my life based on
my values
monica lewinsky what you did look more
power to you
it is what it is i don't know what it is
to be married to hillary i have no clue
what it is to be married to hillary
clinton
i'm gonna assume it's not fun okay i'm
gonna assume it's not fun
so he pushed she pushed him off all that
other stuff i don't know this story
here's what i will tell you when people
were bashing bill clinton you know what
i said i said dude
why don't you go try to get newt
gingrich on the other side to sit there
and negotiate and get our national debt
to be where it's at
i don't really care if there's a monica
lewinsky yeah because i don't know how
hillary is as a wife you ever met a man
married to a miserable woman it sucks
you ever met a woman married to a
miserable guy it sucks
it's absolutely horrible so i don't know
what it is to be married to hillary
but i do know his policies worked during
that time for sure so when you go to
bush and go oh
bush bush this and bush bush is evil i
don't know bush comes across as a very
you know bush senior brilliant guy i
can't sit there and look at bush senior
that guy concerns me a little bit but
his son
seems like a good guy to me you know
what i was drinking whiskey my entire
life and one day i couldn't remember
what happened the night before and i
told my
wife it's the last time i went and took
all the bottles of whiskey and i trashed
him and not there i changed my life and
boom he becomes a president right yeah
you know what
i like that i made some bad decision
when we had him on i was interviewing
him
i made some bad choices in my life well
i made a lot of bad choice in my life
but one guy decided to change
you know what cool respect when you go
to obama people say oh but he's such a
great speaker
i'm like dude he is i just don't like
his policies
you got to be careful with his policies
trump is such an [ __ ]
but his policies for economy i am not
about like for example when they're
talking about abortion
when they talk about abortion yesterday
and the topics came up about
you know roe versus wade what's going to
happen there because that's the biggest
concern what are you going to do one of
the questions was what are you going to
do if they go out there and do this what
is the state of california going to do
and how are you going to handle in your
state because that's the whole thing
with
you know uh uh wanting to tax abortions
have taxpayers pay for the abortion
that's what uh
pence talked about okay pro-life
pro-choice
41 of americans are christians most of
them are what
pro-life 59 of americans are
non-christians
some of them are catholic some of them
are you know uh say other denominations
some of them are pro-life some of them
are pro-choice um
what does it come down to at what point
the definition
of life then you have to figure that
part out but that's a
that's a debate between science faith
that they need to have together
and come out with a timeline right but
that's a social issue
gay gay marriage all this other stuff
gay marriage you want to get gay you
know
get married to a guy dude i went to a
gay club for two years my
best friends were all gay in the army
they were all gay
in the army oh bro they were freaking so
many how many you were in the marines
how many guys did you see like you know
some of these guys were freaking
dude let me tell you how they are let me
put it through this one
in the army no when i said in the army
when i'm in a fort campbell kentucky
dude we had i can't say the names we had
a number of guys at our unit
okay scotty bobby
dude you know how it happened one day we
went to a club we went to a club in uh
tennessee called connections you went to
this club we'd go to every weekend
it was it was studio 54 exactly if
you've seen the movie studio 54 yeah
dude these are some of the coolest cats
were they married i mean were they
but it was one thing you made it clear
it's like listen man here's i'm
i like women just don't don't put your
stuff on my face i'm gonna
put my stuff in your face literally i
said that i said we're gonna get along
you do what you gotta do i'm gonna do
what i gotta do just respect me
hey what's up how you doing hey what's
up greek god all this uh that nickname
because back then you know i had a
physique
i was a greek god i had a good time for
those three was a different run rate
but the point i'm trying to make to use
those are social issues
i don't go to social issues the
challenge with this election is
the emotional people are going to vote
emotionally
and that's a recognition on the amount
of hatred they're driving on trump's
personality and how he is but they're
not going to the policies
if you vote emotionally you will be
controlled emotionally
if you vote logically and you look at
policies you are going to be affected
and the democrats fuel that fire and
they're going to swoop in and that's
what
let me say something actually just to
kind of build upon tom's point
and to build upon your point tom made a
point that i'm sorry
gay marine still sounds funny
don't throw me at that one right there
zero none zero eric over there
so tom made a point which i i actually
agree with he said some people
hate trump so much that they can't see
past their hatred from him and you said
that's how he started his campaign
mexicans are rapists there's good people
in boston so what i'll tell you is this
i have the ability to understand why
people hate trump so much
but i also have the ability to say you
know what i agree with that
okay so as an example people hate trump
so much
from from day one they said i do not
like this person there's no
way i would advocate for this person
there's a way to vote for this person i
hate this person straight up
i just like this person i don't like to
use the word hate they dislike this
person but they hate it
so then when trump does stuff like moves
the um
israel embassy to jerusalem i'm like
that's that's great
good for you when he makes peace in the
middle east with the uae in bahrain
this is peace in the middle east what
are we talking about here how do you
disagree with that
but people and this is like you said
trump's fault
people don't just reverse hate easily if
they say look i do not like this person
four years ago they're not just going to
magically say well i'm coming around
on them they're fixed in just like
people four years ago if they love trump
and he's the best and mega and i they're
not switching from that
so well they're gonna pay a big price
because it's gonna
i mean it's not just hating trump
there's another side that wants to
literally
change the country and how this country
is
how it is going forward and and he's
creating the opportunity
with that personality that people hate
and and when people say this is the
biggest and most important election that
is not hyperbole
i mean that is what's happening here in
less than a month
is really a big deal i got a friend of
mine that called me yesterday
who is involved in some charities some
politics he was in dc for many years so
he's very directly connected with a lot
of the stuff that's happening
he's in his early 70s late 60s
pretty connected politically he said
i've never been this scared about the
future of america
as i am today i said tell me why he said
uh uh
look say trump gets reelected he says
forget about it let's just say trump
does get reelected
so okay he said what happens after four
years
you know what happens after four years
eventually
somebody on aoc and bernie's side is
going to get elected
that's the direction we're going he said
whether it's in four years
it's in eight years it's in 12 years
it's in 16 years it's in 20 years it's
in 24
years it's in 28 years it is going to
happen
and when that happens what happens next
actually think about that so imagine
today aoc is 47.
by the way aoc yesterday say fracking is
bad she tweeted it out so she was
totally like going up here
come on come on kamala harris like what
do you mean defend because they don't
want to understand left is being pulled
to the far left and somebody on even
on the dnc side kamala's the most left
leader a political leader we have today
even further left than bernie is what
they call kamala but anyways
what happens if an aoc gets elected
she's 47.
you gotta you're a dummy if you if you
don't like
aoc i i'm fine with that if you hate her
policies i'm fine with that
but you're naive and a fool if you don't
think she has a career in politics
you're
absolutely not even a fool if you don't
think she says she's got a korean pop
you talk about kamala or aoc no no aoc
aoc is a
superstar for democrats and socialists
superstar for democrats on show you
don't find people like that
that just come around that they're that
good at playing the game
so she's attractive so she's 47. imagine
she's 47.
no no i'm saying when she's 47 i know
she's 30 15 years from now yeah i'm
talking
15 years from now 20 years i'm just 45
or 50 years old okay i didn't realize
she was that young she's a baby exactly
so imagine she's a waitress four years
ago i understand starbucks yeah imagine
she's 45 50 years old
and she runs okay and at that point
right now she's got 8 million followers
on twitter
at that point she's got 50 million
followers 100 million followers
she's a rock type of a person massive
following she runs
she gets elected do you know what
happens to the idea of america
poof it's gone because always remember
this
it's a lot easier to go from capitalism
to socialism than it is to go from
socialism to capitalism
very hard to have a kid being raised in
a family where parents spoiled him
to have a kid be raised in a family
where parents spoiled him
it's very hard to get that kid to go to
a different father that's like wake up
what are you doing
like imagine you're raising a
millionaire's fam a house
and your dad's a millionaire he's got
all the money in the world and you're
sleeping in kicking back everybody loves
you nobody holds you accountable
everything's chill
mom you don't talk to me like that you
don't talk to me like that you know i'm
going to call the cops on your mom you
know those kids ride those breads
say the father dies and the mom the
father didn't do the right things with
the finances now he's broke
now she's broke he's dead she has no
money to herself
he had no life insurance all these
losses taxes she's got to pay
she goes lives in apartment she ends up
marrying a former marine
okay who wakes up in the morning
discipline all this other stuff
that kid the new step that says what are
you doing john
i'm sorry make your bed i don't make my
bed my daddy didn't make me do you know
oh i'm paying the bills buddy you make
your bed give me the key give me your
phone give me this
i hate you okay
i saw like this mom he sucks right
watch this here watch his character
development now flip it yeah flip it
okay kid is got a dad like eric
a marine stud stad hey kid wake up
clean yourself by the way he when he
does meetings i always watch his stuff
what things he says
you can tell a military guy do you clean
after yourself what do we do have to
finish the food
what do you say to your mom what do you
say to this who washes the dishes
what happened with the shoes why don't
you put them over there did you make
your bed
so at first kiss dude eric tells me that
every morning i'm like i'll make my
better
what i'm trying to tell you is this kid
doesn't know better all he knows is
that's what he's raised around
then all of a sudden that father dies
okay
then another father shows up to step
down ah
don't worry about the plate man it talks
sometimes i don't like to do the plate
myself as well oh don't worry about the
bed dude it's all good man
i would put your shoes wherever you want
did i throw my socks there it's okay
mary's gonna your mom's gonna get it
it's easier to go from high standards to
low standards and to go from low
standards to high standards
if we make the flip to eventually an aoc
over the next i'm not worried about
today
i really am not worried about today but
i am worried about 20 or 40 years from
because eventually someone like her is
gonna get elected
i am telling you right now the idea of
america is gone
you're gonna need a second option as a
country and my only concern
my only concern is what is the other
country
left that offers the free enterprise to
freedom of speech to freedom of press
the freedom of all of this other stuff
that america's idea was founded on
what's another country that has that
what is option number two
because eventually the way we're giving
so much of the platform 95 percent of
media control by the left
socialist ideas are being pushed down
our kids throat right now rich people
are bad being told by teachers in school
eventually this is going to work on the
side of them someone is going to get
elected so
today not a big deal four years from now
i think the rights got a good bench
uh with uh whether you call it pence or
whether you call a cruise or
rubio or even some of these charlie
kirk's coming up or candace owns coming
up shapiro's coming up these are all
good people that is
the bench is getting deeper on the right
yeah that at least believe in those
freedoms but the bench on the left is
very deep as well right now very very
yeah but here's the problem the they're
not
day one they're not going to waste this
opportunity if they do get in so i am
worried
about right now almost as much as i am
about 20 years from now
yeah no i i get you but my my worry is
so for example my concern is this uh
when you're in your 20s you can eat
pizza and get away with it remember when
you're in your 20s
like like for example he can eat 15
pizzas nothing will happen to his belly
next day he's going to go to the
bathroom 50 times
okay and the next day he still looks
skinny right
in your 30s what goes you can't eat like
that because your belly pops out a
little bit you go oh
uh salad and salmon please okay
dressing on the side in your 30s you
start saying salad now when the hell did
you ever say salad i have salad
put the dressing on the side and please
take the croutons off
and i'd like this this is what tom does
everything she orders
this is tom yeah exactly you're quoting
them and shawn does like
shawna's right the whole talk about
military well she was holding all of us
accountable
uh try some of this bond what was the
bread at that one place that was right
it was so ridiculous right and they put
like eight in front dude it was so
delicious so shawna was like you gotta
try this
but uh then in your 40s what happened in
your 40s adam what goes in your 40s
your gut bro your metabolism that's 30s
40s is flexibility
40s i haven't gotten that yet i go to
the gym what do you mean
the reason why you don't have it is
because you're always stretching i'm
always every time i see you're
stretching by the way you lost the audio
of adam right
he's stretching okay so and then 50s
what happens
other things go in your 50s right maybe
50s you need to go visit somebody on the
cialis and the viagra side you know
you're like hey doc
this thing is gravity is working against
me many different ways and i can't do
anything about it right
what's the point here here's the point
um
today regardless of what you do
my interest is long-term solution i
don't like band-aids
we are having band-aids today you know
why i like texas what did he say
it's in our constitution constitution
that we will never have state taxes
constitution
that's permanent it gives me a lot of
trust florida has that as well by the
way
but america is getting to a point right
now where i don't know we're about to go
into some weird weird stuff with taxes
so
if we had in the constitution federal
taxes will never be
above 30 percent federal taxes will
never be above 25
in the constitution like it'll never
ever be
above that that gives somebody like me
confidence to know i can go out and do
what i'm doing
but today it's a little bit scary
because i wouldn't be surprised if taxes
go to sixty or seventy percent
over the next ten or twenty they've been
high before like when when reagan was an
actor the story about reagan when he was
an actor in hollywood
yes tax rate was freaking 90 yes but i
don't think
people know that the tax rate in america
above a million above a million was 90
percent it wasn't for everybody
yeah yeah marginal tax rates right like
there was 90
what people are like what are you
talking about how are tax rates that
high
look at tax rates over over the last
hundred years only since basically
the 1970s i want to say 1960s have tax
rates been this low
by the way i didn't even look at the
numbers we got 3 500 people live with us
right that's the highest ever we've had
if you're watching this if you're
enjoying this first of all thanks for
joining us
put the thumbs up comment below uh click
on the subscribe button and the alert
button we got a couple more topics to go
through by the way while this whole
thing is taking place
this morning trump goes on maria
barto-roma
okay and they announce right before that
he gets a message saying that if you
have it kai let's show it
he gets the message saying that they are
thinking about they are moving the
second debate to a virtual debate if you
haven't heard this yet by the way this
just happened this morning
they just announced that they're moving
into virtual debate and this is what
trump had to say about the debate
you got to hear this at the second
debate we have a never trumper as a host
but
that's okay because i'd meet him in the
second debate also
and uh but i'm not going to do a virtual
debate
so you're not so mr president you're not
going to do it because the cpd
the commission on presidential debates
announcing this morning
that the second presidential debate will
be virtual are you saying you're not
going to participate
no i'm not going to waste my time on a
virtual debate that's not what debating
is all about you sit behind a computer
and do a debate it's ridiculous
and then they cut you off whenever they
want uh i have a host who i always
thought was a nice guy but i see he's a
never trumper you know
sounds good another trumper his voice
sounds some of
so you just learned this this morning
yeah we learned it the same way you
learned it they called up uh
two minutes ago and uh it was announced
and they're
trying to protect biden everybody is
they're trying like that nbc disaster
where he went on
the show with lester hult it was like it
was meant for a child
it wasn't meant for a grown person
uh he gets up and he says we're not
fracking we're not fracking he was
fracking for six months he was fracking
he was raising his
his very thin hand and he was fracking
thin hand and now all of a sudden he's
not fracking well tell the pennsylvania
people that you're going
it's ridiculous he said he's not
fracking
that's all he said and then all of a
sudden he goes to a fracking mode and
how about her she committed her life to
it
and all of a sudden she's a fracker
she's a big fracture they're going to
stop fracking the minute they get into
office they're lying to everybody
they're lying about so many different
things
but you have to confront people you
can't do it talk to you about that
i want to talk to you about what you
heard last night but but mr president
you say you're not going to do this
debate
address the criticism mr president the
criticism that you removed your mask for
a photo
op you got to the top of the the steps
you removed it
people are worried about your recent
diagnosis
now you've got 30 plus people with
coronavirus in and around the white
house
address that concern for us mr president
uh
as you tell the commission on debates
you're not going to do this virtually
yeah well first of all i think i'm
better when when
to a point where like i'd love to do a
rally tonight i wanted to do one last
night
uh but i think i'm better to a point
that i feel better than i did
well you know i jokingly said 20 years
ago i feel perfect i feel perfect
there's nothing wrong would you admit
his voice does not sound right i
disagree i think he sounds fine
do you think he sounds fine he's getting
the quips in there if he was sick he
wouldn't be able to draw i'm not talking
about what he's saying
i'm saying an actual voice from heaven
because his voice sounds scratched
because of what i went through
and i had you know i felt pretty lousy a
lot of people did
a lot of people do you know no matter
how good the security that you're not
going to protect yourself from this
thing
with just your standard anything unless
you just literally
you don't come out and even those people
found out did you see in new york city
the most heavily locked down place the
people that caught it the most
were the people that were caught in
their houses in their apartments okay
okay so virtual debate
he says no i'm not going to do it i have
different opinions you heard what i said
uh right before we start a podcast what
do you think is going to happen with the
virtual debate
uh they're going to force it they're
going to force the virtual debate to
happen because he did
test positive for covet 19. he's not
going to do it he has nothing to gain by
doing a virtual debate here's what he
will do
he will go to miami next thursday and he
will have
one big rally i mean it'll be huge
he's going to do something but i don't
think he's going to do this virtual
debate and
and how stupid i mean they are trying to
pull this you know they're trying to
they
they're trying to grease the skids now
for biden completely they've already got
the moderator they want for this second
one who used to be his intern
uh and now turning it into a virtual
debate what
if he tests negative you know for x
amount of days why can't they do it in
person there's no reason
this thing couldn't happen if the doctor
if he's test negative let's see some
tests
the dude just had covid that's not a
that's not a that's not fake news he had
coveted
yeah he may still have covet right it's
not within the 14-day
quarantine window whatever the
ramifications are he's been obviously
been on drugs steroids whatever he got
airlifted to
walter reed hospital is there a chance
he still has coveted that's a question
i mean they're gonna test if he's
negative if if he's negative should they
do the debate
there is negative he should do the
freaking debate about that
that's what biden said as well but this
is the question i'm asking you is the
debate gonna happen live or virtual
i hope it happens live okay so right now
it's virtual
is trump gonna show up to the virtual
debate one thing i'll tell you about
trump as much as i'm not a fan yeah the
dude's a fighter
okay he's a warrior so he's gonna show
up he's gonna i think he'll be there
ready to go if
there's a virtual debate and yeah he'll
do it
he he'll change he'll he'll say yes luis
i believe he wouldn't want to do it but
his
like the party's gonna make him do it
yeah participate i think he's gonna go
to miami
and put that
yeah so by the way here's here's the
thing with trump how many times has
trump said
nope i'm not doing it and then x8 his
mind i mean i just did that with
stimulus that's exactly the point
and he's going to do it again because
look there's
there's nothing he can do about it he
has to do the debate he has to show up
and do the debate so
his camp he's going to realize because
say he doesn't show up to the virtual
debate
guess what the other camp's going to say
very easy opening they want him to say
i'm not going to show up to the debate
because you know what everyone's going
to say he's afraid
and he's sick he's afraid and there's
something we don't know
are you sure what are they not telling
us oh i can only already imagine all
these headlines are going to be
out of this world yeah so he's trump
he's hiding in his basement
he's insider and insider said this is
bigger than kovit
he's dealing with he's going to be live
tweeting during the video but what i'm
trying to say
is he knows he has to show up yeah
of course he's a know it but he knows he
has to show up and here's the thing this
is what i would say if i was his camp
i would say look just show up with one
caveat
what's that that the last debate 100
has to be live no question so do you
agree that the last debate's going to be
live they say yes
fine yeah i'll show people it's that
commission that that debate commission
that sets all the rules yeah
i mean they don't get advice from
anybody that was he didn't even know
about it today yeah so
i don't think anybody has any control
over that commission
this is the problem for all my trump
friends out there respect
this is the problem with agreeing with
everything donald trump says
because the second you agree with him
boom he changes course
just like that just like he did with
stimulus so everyone who just
anything he says i agree with buddy he's
gonna flip it on you on a script
in a second okay just like stimulus it's
not happening forget it no negotiations
are off
stock market tanks all right maybe we'll
bring it back hold on let's see what's
going on
talk about the stimulus very
unpredictable talk about stimulus so he
says it's not gonna
uh i don't support it and we're not
gonna do it until i get elected
the economy the market drops right then
the next day he says
he's considering it what happens the
market goes up 1.9 the dow jones goes up
1.9
yeah 530 points smp gained 58 etc etc
and then day after democratic-led house
panel argues congress should break up
the largest tech companies on anti-trust
president trump's full uh uh uh of
tweets uh when he went what 20 tweets
before 8 a.m something like that he was
sending a bunch of tweets
so the stimulus here's a basic thing
about what do you mean you're not going
to do the stimulus
here's how it works if he says i'm not
going to do the stimulus until after i
get elected you know what happens
he's not going to get elected because
there's one card
he has to be able to keep the next 30
days if he's going to get elected you
know what that is the economy the
economy
if he passes the stimulus people get
money you know what people don't like
they don't like change people don't like
change how did bush get elected they
re-elected the second time even the
people that couldn't stand him he still
got reelected
even the people that couldn't stand
obama he still got re-elected even the
people that couldn't stand up clinton he
still got elected you realize the last
four presidents have all been two-termed
the last time we had a one-term
president was
bush senior so um i think the stimulus
is probably going to be coming up here
very soon
the 1200 i am if i am sent a standalone
bill for
1200 they will go out to our great
people immediately i'm ready to sign
right now trump tweeted on tuesday night
well i give him credit he's
as adamant about flipping and his
enthusiasm about paying the money now
that he
was for not being in favor on monday but
now
write the checks then if that's what it
takes to tell you but i tell you start
the process you know what the bigger
do you know what the bigger story is
here's what the bigger story is here's
what the bigger story is
the bigger story is yesterday kamala
harris used the scariest word
that i hate to hear scares the hell out
of me when i hear them debates you know
what it is
if your family makes less than a hundred
and twenty five thousand dollars a year
everything you're going to get a
community college for
free on the stage if you have any
student loan what joe biden did is he's
going to take ten thousand
dollars off he's gonna bring that up
okay so then free free free right okay
you know what trump is endorsing he's
endorsing
money all free money yeah so this aoc
thing yeah guess what aoc is going to
say
look at this here's how capitalists are
number one capitalism they want
capitalism for others socialism for
themselves
but guess what she's going to say now
these capitalists are secretly
socialists
all they care about is money and she's
right because
this is a socialistic program to come
out with things like this
so long term you know who loses he's
going to pass the stimulus back
long term do you know who loses the
capitalists lose long term
because now they have to do this or else
i don't think so okay i i think this is
a desperate
uh attempt in the final days to do what
you have to do to win
he can flip the script if he gets
re-elected and this is not his policy
socialistic program back to back it's
another way of saying hey i'll give you
money if you vote for me
it is a robin hood uh i think it's like
throwing a hail mary in a football game
normally i don't agree with you dude i
don't disagree with you i'm fully with
you
but i'm telling you right now the same
thing there is the fact that
you yourself are endorsing a socialistic
not you
you yourself are endorsing the
socialistic program so i'm just telling
you
gradually gradually when somebody pushes
you you know the whole thing about you
put a frog and you've heard this before
you've
put a frog in a bowl and you boil the
water
and if you boil it slowly it won't know
that it's getting to 212 degrees before
it dies
as opposed to dropping into the hot pot
jump out immediately you're right
you know i'm cool with him doing
whatever it takes right now in the final
26 days i'll tell you what i mean
chairman of the fed jerome powell came
out and said we need another round of
stimulus straight up
yeah he's came out and said that that
same day trump said no more stimulus
uh trump has one thing going for him
one thing his ace in the hole is
if the economy is doing well he has a
chance for reelection
if everything stays the same my friends
we're going to be looking at a new
president in 2020
okay he i don't know why democrats would
at this point in the game
send out more stimulus checks why
wouldn't they just wait another month
till after the election here
he should pray that he cuts a deal in
the next month to send checks to people
to curry favor for a vote he should want
that the fact that he says no more
checks
doesn't help him that's why someone
probably said dude what are you doing
flip court and the next day boom change
his course so he's
very rational very erratic and and he
came out and i think very emotional and
wasn't like in the way the direction
that stimulus was headed he's been like
that since 2016. now
so so for me when you are the way you
are and you consistently are the way you
are i'm not surprised i'm not surprised
no i don't think anyone is surprised
nobody's shocked that he reversed course
a part of a part of his ability this is
the part that people don't realize
about his ability he's all about being
unpredictable
when you're under he's all about being
unpredictable he's not about being
predictable he's all about being
unpredictable and that's been his play
and and and i tell you part of that
being unpredictable i want you to be
unpredictable towards the enemy i don't
mind that if you're unpredictable
i'm good with you on that yeah i'm good
if you're unpredictable with china
i'm good if you're unpredictable in
north korea not if you're unpredictable
you support china yeah i support you you
support shanna because if you support
biden you support trump that's not true
at all it's not true
that's not true wait it's not i'm just
not a fan of being unpredictable
go on that topic if okay so here's a
question for you don't try to put me up
no that's
a china here's a question i'm not a fan
of china here's a question for you
here's a question for you
you ready okay give me your top five
main concerns
what are your top five main concerns
right now you have in life when it comes
down to politics
what is it my personal concern what like
with this election what are your five
policies talked about policy not
emotions not personality policies
i would say first and foremost is the
economy what's going on jobs
unemployment stay there but let's go
through this together so let's actually
do this together
we're gonna have fun right now together
you guys should have been in the
boardroom yesterday but economy is
number one what's your number two
what the hell is going on with covid
with stimulus with stuff like that
but be specific more covet like vaccine
everything's surrounding kovitz but it's
different okay so stimulus
stimulus checks what's happening with
that why what's happening why is that a
problem what's happening with airlines
priority to you why is that a priority
to you
for my fellow americans people are
really hurting americans okay people are
hurt i'm good
let me just be clear what if trump's
elected or binds elected adams i know
you are what i'm asking you is yes
you're a reasonable guy yes attendance
and you're a pretty smart guy
yes unfairly and ninety percent category
is where you are yes
yes or no i mean minus b plus what i'm
trying to say is you've always done
you're good
you weren't the guy that played ball
that had a three that had a 2.0 no you
had a 3.5 gpa yeah
you're a smart guy i know you say i
don't like to do politics you're
actually very good
very well it was more like i like to
party on the weekends but i like the
good school i like to play sports i was
more i don't know who you are you're
well-rounded i talk to you all the time
you're actually a very smart guy adams
are very very smart i know some of you
guys are putting all this sword boy
stuff
adam's a very very soyboy mafia thank
you i'm embracing what is your sincere
what's your concern right now about the
future
stimulus is a concern for you for the
future i'm
for my fellow americans there's a lot of
people unemployed
okay there's a lot of industries that
are hurting fine give me another one
okay
china is very high on that list where do
you put it on the list
is it in your top three top five top ten
number three i just looked at number
three what's number four
um for me yeah race relations in this
country
like let's stop burning down let's stop
the writing let's stop the looting let's
stop the divisiveness
but that's on one side politically so to
both sides it's very divisive
uh not the right not the approach no one
on the right there's no one on the far
right there's no one on the kkk side
there's no one on
the white nationalist side and looting
looting like businesses burning down
business that's on the left that's on
the left
but there's nobody on the right you're
trying to the left to stop rioting
i would like better race relations in
our country that's not going to happen
why would that not happen because the
more divided we are the one
the better it is for politics you think
we're better for politics if we're
united like you have got to be
better for politics though are you
they're better off
pinning you against other people kind of
don't want that you're not going to do
world peace
that is trump's go-to card pinning the
pinning
pinning black versus white but every
single time somebody tried to do
something with
with obama it was a race card it was
because he's black every single time
somebody said something you can say
anything
every time you post a view that obama
had you're racist
this has been going on for 12 years
every single time somebody said
something you must be racist
so this is not going away but give me
your next issues but but i'll put that
on the list as well black lives matter
matters to you we'll put that here i
didn't say that that that's what i'm
saying race relations
which is blm actually no i wouldn't say
bl i would just say
race relations i would say i would say
listen i have
some best friends that are republican
what else i have best friends i know you
democrats
i just want people to get along i want
people to listen to each other and
respect each other's opinions i've seen
you behind closers you actually really
want that
i do i do i know you do so i'm giving it
to you i'm saying i know you so what's
your fifth one
i mean number four is probably i would
put that actually even higher so
economy stimulus china obviously our
situation with that
um yeah i don't know they say it's four
of them
that's fine if you can't come up with
another one let's just say i mean the
supreme court is pretty high
the second amendment is pretty high um
is supreme court down high to you if it
is i'll put it down it's not i'm just
saying it's high up on my list
let's just stay here then okay sure is a
part of economy having to do with taxes
yes it is are you wanting corporate
taxes to go up or to stay where it's at
i'd like corporate taxes to stay where
it is well just so you know one side is
going to raise it one side is not so
biden so does trump get the
vote for you on the economy side or
biden does on
taxes on taxes i would go on the right
side yes okay if there was no covid you
think dow jones today would have been at
thirty five thousand
potentially yeah okay it was trending in
that direction if there was no covet uh
first time ever median income has hit
sixty three thousand dollars we haven't
seen that for 25 years on both sides of
the administration it's the first time
it's happened
so so are you going to put economy taxes
on the one thing trump has gone from is
the economy
so i'm giving him that okay giving him
that so stimulus he's pulled the
stimulus once and he's about to do it
again so if he does it is he though he
just said
if he does does he get your vote if he
does in this topic specifically to
stimulus
i think the democrats care more about
people getting stimulus
more about um checks he being mailed out
i think they
they're they think it's because they
care more it's because they're going to
be able to control an audience i think
they're looking to buy votes okay
so then who who's which side are you
going to give can we say this one is
lost because they're both full of it
i think they're just trying to win i
think they're all just no on this
category i think both
i don't want the federal deficit the
debt to go up higher it's going to true
but they're both yeah i don't want so
let's put this one as a non-issue okay
china which side do you trust more
against china
i i do applaud trump for exposing china
there's there's been a problem with
china so okay
you you are more confident knowing that
trump is going to go against china then
biden's going to go against china i
would say
but he's very erratic but you said
that's a good thing yeah you said that's
a good thing i don't mind it
okay so let's put trump here riots blm
yeah i think you're probably on biden's
side
yes so do you realize on your main
issues
you agree more with yourself two and two
no you're not two and two no you're not
even stimulus is even they're both going
to do to buy the votes i'm veering left
on that one
i'm two and two in what way though you
just said they want to do it because
they get i think
people do need uh i think trump has done
it
he's done it he's given all the stimulus
that people have asked he's done he just
said he's not though well he said he
changed his mind he's doing it he
changes his mind every day what i'm
saying is say he does it then that's a
voter
i see what you're doing here yeah what i
mean i respect it yeah you're saying all
right let's see your top
issues and let's prove my point out
there's a hatred of trump right
what i'm what writes everything what i'm
trying to say is
forget about the guy it's impossible
but but if you can't do it possibly but
you know what you're saying if you say
that you know what you're saying if you
say that
you know what you're saying if you say
that that i'm an emotional creature
you're not rational that you can't
rationally
reason because rational irrational would
be
dude there's nothing i agree with no
matter what he does i hate him
that's irrational rational is saying i
don't really care for the guy but here
are the things i do enjoy i run a
company
okay and uh uh uh you know i don't
expect everybody to
like my style of driving people i don't
like i don't expect them to like it
okay but i do know behind closed doors
they'll sit there and say
this freaking guy gets stuff done what
am i gonna do every single time
something happens company's improved
simple as that i i trust this guy at the
top right one of the girls we work with
um her name is diana i got to give a
shout-out they're killing right her
husband kilroy
you know when she first came in she sat
at my house on december 31st of 2010.
okay
oh and we were talking at the time
and she said one of my concerns is you
come across as being reckless with money
that's what she says to you and she says
i worry
because to run a startup i don't know
how you handle money
i worry about the way you handle money
it's okay and she said some other
concerns that she has with me
by the way she has the right to think
that's in 2010 yes okay
fast forward four years later you know
what she tells me she says pat you know
i had no idea
you were this conservative with money
behind closed doors
i had no idea how conservative you were
with money behind closers you have no
idea how much confidence it gives me
then i'm driving and challenging her
today
she's one of the best people in the
company her and her husband dynamic
they're absolutely crushing it right now
right
she says i am now thankful for how you
challenged us to improve right
but for a period you know she didn't
like my approach because i was hard
charging challenging all this other
stuff
we have personalities in the company
that they don't get along
okay when it comes down to values and
principles
we do get along when it comes under
personalities you don't get along
if you only want to work with
personalities that you get along with
you're going to have a problem
for me has zero to do with personalities
it's all about values and principles
if i can sit there and tell you
philosophically
i'm on this page with you
philosophically i don't care how
annoying of a person you are
we're on the same page with values and
principles we're on the same page with
philosophies
i'm good with you if i can't do that
rationally
and be reasonable i'm an emotional human
being i'm always going to be controlled
for the rest of my life i don't want to
be controlled and it just comes down to
the fact that no one can get past the
fact that they hate trump you want to
know what my
fears are or my the same question you
asked adam here
a socialism is on the fast track if
biden wins
i am concerned about the supreme court
because they're going to stack it and
they're going to change
everything that they possibly can
they're going to make dc estate they're
going to make puerto rico estate
they're going to flip the electoral
college process our freedoms are going
to be gone
they're going to have a game plan that
they've got now to shut down the country
and control us even more they've done
that check that off the box capitalism
you can kiss it goodbye
um you know the free money california is
doing this thing right now
garcetti came out where he says that
everybody's gonna get a handout free
money just for being alive
they're just gonna hand it out and then
i'll tell you another thing the
lawlessness in this country is going to
be off the charts it's going to be
insane there's not going to be any money
to uh to pay for law and order and
police forces and whatnot
and then here i'll tell you where it's
going to go the the
more conservative level-headed people in
this country
when the dust settles if they lose are
going to be so pissed off that they
allowed it to happen
we allowed the media to completely
manipulate us to control the messaging
that there will be more unrest than you
think there could be
some sort of civil war yeah i mean if
you want to call in if you had asked me
that two years ago
i would say the there is less chance of
a civil war in the united states than
any other scenario possible including
aliens landing on the u.s i just thought
there was no way it could happen
now i'm almost convinced it will it's a
very good point kai do you have that usa
to the article about civil war or no do
you have it up if you don't it's all
good but
uh i don't think we had it on our list
let me know if you do or you don't
just tap in usa today's civil war okay
when is the last time you saw usa today
civil war yeah there you go civil war uh
papa papa papa it's not three hours it's
uh
disagree uh it was an article that came
okay right there
half the voters if you go up go up go up
go up go up over half the voters expect
violence watch this
this is yesterday okay no let me just
read the headline
thank you the country's lost its mind
paul's warning of civil war violence
shows deep partisan chat chasm
over election i mean when is the last
time usa today said something like that
you
the poll of 1999 registered voters found
that nearly half 47
disagree with the idea that election is
likely to be fair and honest and that's
slightly more than 51 percent
more than half 51 percent want to
generally agree on who is legitimately
unlike the president united states the
online poll was conducted october 1st
through 2nd and has a margin error of
plus minus 2.56 percent okay so
look polls you know how i feel about
polls i'm not big on polls but to say
we're headed towards civil war how the
hell do we get here so again
for me it goes back down to
it's okay it's not a big deal let that
policy go through
it's okay it's you know the whole
compromise thing oh my gosh when people
say compromise it's one of the
you got to give something to get
something that's not that's not the
truth
there is no such thing like compromise
let me explain to what i mean by
compromise
so say you and i like look what eric
just did
eric just said what no not not where i
was at
okay with the marines eric didn't
compromise
eric just said what no i didn't see it
on my unit great i started my unit
eric didn't say yes he said what no
not in my unit okay we're living in a
time
where we think everything's about
compromise it's not about compromise
it's about what's the best thing to do
if the system america created
has fundamentally done better than all
of these other nations
combined only in 244 years or whatever
the timeline is
what the hell are we doing questioning
that system improving it
yes fundamentally changing it it's scary
there's a there is a concern for me when
it comes down to
uh when you win and you start doing
really good
a couple things happens to you and i see
this i had a conversation one of my
favorite guys in the company i said it
was a 45 minute conversation pretty
intense conversation the conversation
was
you're getting solved he says i'm not
getting something he accused you
i called him and i said you're getting
sober oh i told him i said you're
getting soft
and he says what do you mean i'm getting
sobbed i said success has gotten you
soft and i said you have to be very very
careful he says what do you mean
i said brother let me put it to you this
way
the moment you start winning and
everything you wanted
for instance like you you want to be
making a lot of money lifestyle house
attention all the stuff that you wanted
that comes with a price
what's the price you're officially a
target
america is the greatest country in the
world no problem you're officially a
target
what happens when it's a target people
are not happy about it who the hell
likes losing
you know how much people love when they
saw golden state warriors there were
people on twitter
celebrating when kevin durant got hurt
when klay thompson remember when he went
for the layup he got hurt he held his
leg
called his dad like dude this guy's done
they were celebrating they should have
won and beaten the
toronto raptor they should have been a
champion people were celebrating that
they got hurt
celebrating when they got hurt why
because for five years they embarrassed
everybody
a little guy six one became a two-time
mvp
embarrassing a lebron james a behemoth
of a player pre kevin durant
let's remember this day one pre kevin
durant they hated him now you're a
target that's what comes with the
territory
when you start winning but when you
start winning
the part i like about trump which is
very interesting
if you saw when he got on that show with
uh uh ali g with uh sasha cohen
and sasha cohen's trying to kind of fool
around with him right yeah do you see
what he the moment he noticed there's
games going on
he just said well i wish you nothing but
the best well good luck guys all the
best good luck okay thank you good luck
good luck and he walked off
he didn't say anything he just walked
off he still has
his you know instincts instincts he's
still got that paranoid thing knowing
that he's a target
he knows he's a target unfortunately the
american politicians when they become
politicians here's what happens
when you go to dinner with a celebrity
first time if you're around a celebrity
or
somebody that's a big name what do you
become google gaga it's like
oh my gosh oh my gosh luke cuomo hey how
you doing
you got to be loyal to your friends
[ __ ] i'm loyal to america
that's who my loyalty is first you have
to be loyal to the country that gave you
the opportunity to become who you became
not loyal to your foreign you know like
what kamala said
you have to be loyal that's the advice
that biden gave i'm sorry
the the more and more you just kind of
say it's okay it's okay
it's okay it's okay half a percent here
point two percent here point one percent
here
then suddenly you're going to wake up
and you're gonna see they're living in
your living room
sleeping in your bed kicking back over
here there's a line you can't cross
and we have let that line constantly go
a little bit further back a little bit
further back a little bit further back
now we're in too deep if people don't
stand up and realize that this great
idea
founded in 1776 that attracted a kind of
an economy the industrial growth that
we've had where everybody around the
world wants to model this economy
secretly every country around the world
minus a handful of them that religiously
disagree with what we believe in
secretly every country in the world
wants to be like america
secretly of course they want to be like
america and we're and we're letting that
go it's a little bit scary
if you think about it if countries
were a company guess what this means to
other countries
an opportunity if i am another country
and i'm costa rica i'm panama i'm sweet
i'm any of these other i'm no i'm any of
these other countries you know what i'm
thinking about here's what i'm thinking
let's attract some of these people who
are going to leave
i'm going to put a 50-year plan together
i'm going to put a 20 to 50 year old
plant together you know what i'm going
to start doing exactly what abbott did
but with my country i'm going to do what
abby did with my country says i asked
nassac to come to texas here's why
we just signed something our
constitution that we will never have
state taxes
you know what i'm doing if i'm another
country if you're an entrepreneur
living in america you're worried about
losing all your rights your freedoms all
this other taxes
come consider us whatever the country is
if i'm a pm or president of another
country i'm drooling right now
because the biggest behemoth is about to
lose talent
and if you make an environment for me to
go there that i'm going to get the
freedom
another country officially has the
opportunity to have an opening cure yeah
but you need some forward-thinking
countries and i hope there are some i
hope
i hope something great there certainly
is there certainly is it's just you just
can't be afraid of doing that but there
certainly is going to be
uh someone's got that gotta have this
let me ask you a second uh yeah a
follow-up question because you started
everything you just said with the word
compromise right
so there are certain things that you
would not compromise your values and
principles you would not compromise
those whatsoever no
but you do need to compromise from time
to time
that's not like you go your throughout
your entire life not compromising
you go through a negotiation you
compromise they're going through these
stimulus negotiations
you have to compromise democrats are
initially at two
at three trillion republicans are at one
trillion you have to compromise to get
to two trillion
so there's things that you should not
compromise your values are principles
cool who you are as a person
proud to be an american no compromise
there but when you're negotiating when
you're in a board room when you're
when you're on the congress floor you
have to compromise
you can't see compromise but i disagree
you can't see compromise as a bad thing
no i disagree with you tell me why and
there lies the problem
there lies a problem because um
look there's something called
non-negotiables okay
we are we are compromising our
non-negotiables
i understand compromising small stuff
meaning hey
we're going to put ti 500 000 into this
building okay great
and uh i want you to put such and such
here this year okay i can do that but i
can't do the ac because we're dealing
with five hundred thousand dollars it's
a budget
fine got it okay no problem
non-negotiable
if you're not paying for the ac i'm not
even doing it no problem
then if all of a sudden say you know
what don't worry instead of three aces
just put one those guys in the back
don't really need it anyways they're
going to get it from the other place no
i'm not compromising my non-negotiables
america is compromising its
non-negotiables bro
they're compromising their
non-negotiation you never
compromise your non-negotiables not with
your kids
not with your spouse not with your
family not with the people you work with
never your non-negotiables
i'm on the same page so clearly but what
we're doing we said values and
principles non-negotiable
non-negotiation but there's things that
are negotiable of course there's things
that that's true everything is not
but you're saying that you don't
compromise at all you compromise every
day no except for non-negotiable
sure if i sit with you and you say
something to me
and i'm disagreeing with you i'm not
looking to be right
i'm looking for the best solution that
long term is best for everybody
if you propose something that's better
for me long term and it's i'm wrong
i'm not trying to well compromise with
me here no i'm saying
we're going with you buddy because i'm
not trying to be right
i'm trying to be what what's the best
thing for us to grow the company
that's not compromising that's saying
you were right i was wrong we didn't
compromise you won
there is no compromise there i don't
know if i'm making sense
you're saying that it's more than a
compromise your reverse course it's not
compromise it's what's the best decision
what's the best choice and what are we
not negotiating
certain things are off the table bro
what i can say these three things are
off the table everything else let's talk
about it
but that's not what we're doing as
politicians as politicians everything's
on the table
you just saw right now we're going to
raise the supreme court you know uh
from 9 to 15 and the last time that's
happened 150 years they're willing to do
they don't
want to answer that's not compromising
that's not compromising
yeah that's radical yeah that's great
exactly yeah that's a concern so
anyways guys we have a lot of other
topics to cover but we're at 953 do we
want to hit one more topic here if we do
which one you want to hit
you guys want to pick a topic here that
we got we got lots of topics here
we got to talk about jay baldwin j bob
no you know you know what we got to tell
what we can talk about
is uh um huh
oh that's not what i heard that's too
heavy to end it with it's too heavy dude
you want to do blm lebron james do you
want to do uh
what
let's talk about nba this year all right
the heat baby
for two more days gosh the first time
i'm talking about that i know it's crazy
nba to leave black lives matter social
justice messaging off the floor next
season says commissioner adam silva
we're completely committed to standing
for social justice and racial equality
and that's been the case
uh going back for decades silver said in
an interview it's been part of our dna
of this league
how it gets manifested is something
we're going to have to sit down
with the players and discuss for next
season i would say in terms of messaging
you see on the courts and jerseys this
was an extraordinary moment in time
when we began the discussions with the
players and that's what we all live for
this are my senses that there will be
somewhat of a return back to normal
normalcy that those messages will
largely be left to be delivered on the
floor and i understand those people are
saying i'm on your side but i want to
watch basketball
games so meaning we're not re viewership
is down according to post on sports
media watch sundays night games game
three between the lakers and hit average
5.94 million viewers
the least watched nba finals game on
record it topped the previous low of
6.61 million
which was set on friday game two yeah
i'm going to give silver a mulligan on
this season because everything was just
completely whacked and warped and i
think this bubble mentality
they did a great job they really did a
phenomenal job they controlled covet
inside they didn't have any tests
that were positive the whole time
they've been there since january or
since july
the playoff basketball has been great
the level of play has been really good
their ratings are in the toilet
um it's his only option at this point
because they've turned off probably 40
of their audience that don't even want
to watch it anymore and but
you know what his hands were tied it was
it was a crazy time
silver's a smart guy he's doing the
right thing um you know part of the
reason their ratings are down to i don't
like watching basketball without fans
without energy without like some sort of
intensity in there
uh it's completely different and you're
not used to watching basketball in
october this
is football season so people are wired a
little bit differently but it's
like this is this is just another
example of how everything that we
thought we knew in this country is being
changed in front of our eyes we got a
taste of it with nba basketball
multiply that by a hundred that's what
our country's gonna be if it goes a
certain way
on november third but silver is rational
i give him a lot of credit for saying no
we are going to go back to where this
can't go on for a second year
yeah i i i was actually i thought it was
a for sure this was a one-time thing
just during the bubble i don't think
this was a big story i thought for sure
but i i why not do it for a week the
fact that they did it for five months
you know that that's where they lost me
a little touche i don't know but
uh certainly things are strange times
it's in the bubble i will say
much respect to whoever's running the
show uh the anti-covet campaign over
there
in the bubble zero cases no question
about the same thing cannot be said
about whoever's running the show in the
white house
more cases in the white house than in
the nba bubble that's a shocker to me
yeah
or the nfl or the other sports or
college football
you know what happened with cam newton
recently yeah but the bubble creates the
advantages right yeah because she should
be a freaking bubble in the white house
i don't want to see white house haven't
coveted i don't know regardless of your
political policy
i appreciate you you want to see you
want to see white house bubble uh white
house covenant i respect your emotions
buddy i respect your emotions you know
for me i uh i i think silver is doing a
better job than godel if you ask me
silver at least got to the issue
immediately he addressed it and they're
moving on
godel made a kaepernick issue a
four-year issue
uh silver made it a five-month issue and
it's going to be done they'll move on to
next year so good for him
i'm not a fan of the product today the
nba i'm just not a fan of product today
i think
every time i hear an nba player do a
vote video you only have one choice for
vote you don't have another choice for
vote it's not like a vote
they're saying vote for who we're
telling you to vote for yeah
not go vote it's not saying that's the
what i would love is i'd love two
teammates sitting next to each other one
wearing a
blm shirt and another one wearing a mega
shirt hugging each other i'd love to see
that
there was a picture that came the other
day that went viral on social media i
don't know if you saw that two neighbors
post the picture one had a biden kamala
harris
sign on and a shirt on and the other one
had a trump
pence shirt on and they took a picture
and it went viral awesome
to see more i'd love to assume i would
love to see i would love the nba and
and adam silver to allow one person to
wear a mega shirt in the nba i've never
seen that i'd love to
i'd love to see that happen the guy
would be crucified
from the top if he didn't we talked
about the the one guy who did not know
uh jonathan isaac the one guy who did
not kneel for the anthem first time in
my life blew his knee out the next game
in my life i'm not rooting for this guy
first time well it's unbelievable the
lakers are one day away from clinching a
title that should be a big deal i feel
the same way i just
i live there and i don't even feel like
they're part of the city yeah yeah it is
what it is so gank
uh phenomenal uh being with you today i
think we cracked three uh 3800 at one
point or 37.50 at one point
if you're still with us here press the
thumbs up right there uh subscribe uh
click on the alert button we are most
likely going to be doing the
presidential debate next week i do not
believe we're doing a podcast next
tuesday
i am not available next tuesday but we
will do the next podcast next thursday
uh whether there is or not we're doing
one next week but if there is a debate
we're going to put it right now as the
calendar being 7 p.m
next thursday i wish we could do these
on a daily basis but none of our
schedules permits us to do that
and then outside of that if you haven't
yet gone to vtpost.com
and checked out the content that we're
putting together go to vtpost.com
we just launched a new site if you want
to be a contributor
you can go apply to be a contributor
next week or two we are finalizing the
people who are chosen to be contributors
but again go to vtpost.com it's a new
site that we
launched uh just this tuesday
and it's creating a lot of traction
right now so go to vtpost.com subscribe
to the newsletter
and uh we will see you next thursday for
the following podcast have a great week
everybody take care
bye bye bye
[Laughter]
you